foreign
welcome to another installments of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
exploring death in Harry Potter Death is
a central theme to The Harry Potter
books playing a vital role in both
Harry's life and experiences at Hogwarts
near the very beginning of the first
book right from the get-go were given
information pertaining to the deaths of
Harry's parents and given a glimpse into
what sort of an impact it had on him and
his life
but it wasn't just Harry that dealt with
death in fact the primary antagonists
had a unique relationship to death as
well with Voldemort constantly pushing
for a way of achieving immortality
Voldemort's obsession with living
forever and the value he placed in the
world of the living is repeated over and
over throughout the books and films to
him there is nothing worse than dying
there is nothing worse than death
Dumbledore snarled Voldemort you are
quite wrong said Dumbledore one of the
main messages of the Harry Potter books
is that death is not absolute nor is it
something that we should be worrying
about it's continually reinforced that
death is simply a part of life and that
instead our focus should be on seeking
love and friendship enjoying the time
that we do have but for some like
Voldemort that message will never
resonate which is why all sorts of
methods of achieving immortality have
been concocted in the Wizarding World
today we're going to be uncovering all
five of these methods let's get into it
one time magic the Harry Potter story is
right with all sorts of inaccuracies and
inconsistencies when it comes to the
manipulation of time this is expected
however as fully diving into a complex
subject like time travel would probably
require a dedicated book worth of
explanations all on its own with Dan
said however time and how it can be
manipulated is haphazardly approached in
Harry Potter which means it's on our
radar in the department of mysteries
inside the ministry of magic there's
even a Time room a place dedicated to
the complex field of study
but what if I told you that immortality
could be achieved Through Time Travel
while I haven't fully explored how this
could be possible it seems in theory a
little dubious as presumably you'd still
age regardless of where you traveled to
in time but in Harry Potter there's a
way around that during the battle inside
the ministry of magic we see a Death
Eater whose head is trapped in a bell
jar transforming back and forth from
being a baby to an adult look out the
devil horrified he was staring at the
death eater's head in the Bell jar all
three of them raised their ones again
but none of them struck they were all
gazing open-mouthed appalled at what was
happening to the man's head it was
shrinking very fast growing Bolder and
Bolder the black hand stubble retracting
into his skull his cheeks becoming
smooth his skull round and covered with
a peach-like fuzz a baby's head now sat
grotesquely on top of the thick muscled
neck of the Death Eater as he struggled
to get up again but even as they watched
their mouths open the head began to
swell to its previous proportions again
thick black hair was sprouting from the
paint and Chin in theory if you were to
get your entire body into the jar you'd
regress to being a child and presumably
gain the ears back however this would
not be useful unless you'd be able to
preserve your adult memories in the
process nonetheless this is a way of
achieving immortality 2. Philosopher's
Stone the Philosopher's Stone was
created by Nicola Flamel a French crime
born in the year 1330 in the city of
pontoir Flamel was adapted from a real
world historical figure was one of the
longest living Wizards in Harry Potter
dying just shy of 700 years old but if
lameld wanted to he could have lived
forever and that's because he was the
inventor and primary holder of the
Philosopher's Stone
one of the main functions of the
Philosopher's Stone was to turn any
metal into gold which could have made
anyone who held it in their possession
very rich but while that may sound
impressive that was only the Stone's
second most important capability with a
magical artifact like the Philosopher's
Stone in your hands you could have
eternal life
Flamel along with his wife perranel were
able to produce an elixir of life from
the stone allowing them to live
ludicrously long lives in fact both of
them would have been able to live
forever but fomel aware of the dangers
of what could happen of the stone fell
into the wrong hands destroyed it as far
as living forever goes this may have
been the best way of achieving it as
fullmel never seemed to have any side
effects from The Elixir he created
what's important to note however is that
Flamel did appear to look very
physically old whether that's a product
of the stone simply slowing the physical
aging process or an outcome of Flamel
only starting to use the stone in later
life is unclear the best part about the
Philosopher's Stone it may even exist
outside of Harry Potter I did not invent
the concept of the Philosopher's Stone
which is a legendary substance that was
once believed to be real and the true
goal of alchemy the properties of my
Philosopher's Stone conform to most of
the attributes the Ancients ascribed to
it the stone was believed to turn base
Metals into gold and also to produce the
elixir of Life which could make you
immortal genuine Alchemists the
forerunners of chemists and physicists
such as Sir Isaac Newton and the real
Nicola Flamel sought sometimes of the
lifetimes to discover the secret of its
creation 3. Unicorn Blood during one of
Harry's first visits to the Forbidden
Forest he stumbles upon Voldemort
drinking the blood of a slain unicorn at
this point in time Voldemort was still
in his non-corporeal form but by
possessing quarrel he was able to use
him to drink the blood on his behalf
furthermore corbel's body was dying as
it was hosting Voldemort after scaring
off Voldemort the Centaur forenze
explains Unicorn Blood to Harry the
blood of a unicorn will keep you alive
even if you're an inch from Death
without a terrible price you have slain
something pure and defenseless to save
yourself and you will have but a
half-life a cursed life from the moment
the blood touches your lips it seems
like drinking Unicorn Blood despite
potentially being one of the worst
options is a valid way of achieving
immortality however you will need to
continually drink it to have a sustained
effect
4. potions in chapter 8 of the
Philosopher's Stone Snape introduces the
subject of potion making you are here to
learn the subtle signs and exact art of
potion making as there is little foolish
one waving here many of you will hardly
believe this is Magic I don't expect you
will really understand the beauty of the
softly simmering cauldron with its
shimmering fumes the delicate power of
liquids that creep through human veins
bewitching the mind and snaring the
senses I can teach you how to bottle
Fame Brew Glory even stop a death if you
aren't as big a bunch of dunderheads as
I usually have to teach and what I want
to focus on is the last part where Snape
says stopper death the potion Snape
mentions here is not referenced anywhere
in Canon and it's entirely possible that
Snape was simply trying to impress his
students but this potion is mentioned
nonetheless
another potion that I theorize could
possibly sustain life is the Polyjuice
Potion as we know polyju's potion allows
witches and wizards to transform into
and take on the appearance of others
however the specifics of this potion are
never disclosed like just how closely
you resemble the witch or wizard after
the transformation do your internal
organs change do you take on their
Vitality if apologies potion truly does
change everything about a witch or
wizard then it's entirely possible that
one could continually leverage polyju's
potion in order to continually transform
into younger healthier witches and
wizards essentially staying alive
forever
5. horcruxes of the horcrux wickedest of
magical inventions we shall not speak
nor give direction you knew it was
coming horcruxes are potentially the
most well-known method of achieving
immortal reality this of course being
due to the fact that this was
Voldemort's method of choice a horcrux
is created when a wizard takes an object
and binds a piece of their soul to it
the purpose is immortality with the
logic going that as long as a piece of
your soul survives within the object
then you can never truly die it's magic
so dark so heinous that it was kept a
secret from most of the Wizarding World
to make a horcrux a damaged piece of
one's Soul must be removed from the
Creator's body and put into an inanimate
object or living host making the crater
Immortal in order to do this the witch
or wizard who wishes to split their soul
needs to commit the ultimate act of
violence and evil murder and not just
any murder they have to deliberately
kill someone without regrets or remorse
it must be done with the utmost evil
intent resulting in a metaphysical
damaging of the murderer's Soul after
they have killed their victim the witch
or wizard uses a powerful incantation to
remove this damaged part of their soul
from their body placing it in a vessel
outside of themselves and then
performing an unknown ritual to bound
the fragmented soul to its new container
grating horcruxes though effective is
certainly one of the most extreme and in
my opinion in advisable ways of
achieving immortality as if things go
south you may just end up like Voldemort
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember to the well-organized Mind
death is but the next great adventure